في غايه بكهف مظلم وموحش ظلوا عالقين لمده
تسعه ايام كامله لا انيس لوحشتهم ولا غطاء
يقيهم برد المكان ولا سبيل لهم للخروج
قصه انقاذ حبس فيها العالم انفاسه ووصفت
بالمعجزه بعد انقطاع الامل في الوصول الى
12 طفلا علقوا في احد كهوف تايلاند
بتاريخ 23 من يونيو عام 2018 مجموعه من 12
فتى في الفريق كره قدم محلي تايلاندي
اعمارهم تنوحت بين 11 و16 سنه احتجز مع
مدربهم في عمق اربعه كيلومترات داخل كهف
يدعى تعمل
في منطقه تشانجري تايلانديه الاطفال هو
مدربهم كانوا في رحله استكشافيه داخل
الكهف لكنه طول امطار غزيره تسببت في غمره
جزئيا ما ادى الى احتجازهم داخله بعد
ساعات على اختفائهم تم ابلاغ السلطات على
الفور الطلبه هو مدربهم مفقودون منذ ساعات
السلطات التايلانديه تحركت على الفور
وبدات عمليات البحث المكثفه دون وجود ادنى
فكره لدى رجال الانقاذ عن مكان الاطفال او
ان كانوا لا يزالون على قيد الحياه الجهود
تواصلت رغم تغلب التعب والارهاق على رجال
الانقاذ
زاد الطين بله مياه الامطار التي عرقلت
عمليه البحث اخيرا استطاع رجال الانقاذ
تحديد مكان الاطفال انهم هناك داخل الكهف
المرعب تحديد موقعهم لم يكن كافيا فارتفاع
منسوب مياه الامطار مناعه من الدخول الى
الكهف حتى ان احدهم لاقي حد فاهو خلال
محاوله لوضع اسطوانات اوكسجين في طريق
خروج محتمل مع نفاد الوقت عرضت جهات امنيه
للمساعده الجيشان الامريكي والبريطاني دخل
على خط العمليه وسط تغطيه اعلاميه مكثفه
ومتابعه عالميه والكل يترقب متى تحين ساعه
الفرج وهل سيخرج الاطفال احياء
عمليات البحث دخلت يومها التاسع وهنا قررت
الحكومه التايلانديه اقحام الضفادع
البشريه 90 غواصا غطسوا في المياه التي
ملات الكهف محملين بامال الملايين ممن
تابع حدث حول العالم ربما
[موسيقى]
بعد رحله شقه الغواصين تطلبت منهم المشيه
بمعداتهم وتسلق صخور الكهف ثم الغوص حصلت
المعجزه وصلنا الى الاطفال ومدربهم جميعهم
على قيد الحياه
ويتمتعون بصحه جيده
[موسيقى]
الاطفال الى المستشفى لعلاج المصابين منهم
وغادروا بعد ايامه فقط من العلاج حياه
جديده كتبت لفتيه الكهف بعد انقطاع الامل
في نجاتهم وعبره كبيره من قصتهم تعلمها
العالم اجمع بضروره التعاون والتكافل لا
سيما في الظروف الانسانيه الصعبه
[موسيقى]